بادواته من منزله وافكاره المبتكره استطاع
الشمس سعودي فواز الزهراني ان يقدم مقاطع
فيديو وصور مميزه يمثلها بنفسه على تطبيق
تيك توك حققه من خلالها شهره ومشاهده
عاليه فهو يخرج ويمثل ويصور مشاهد مميزه
جدا استخدم فواز فناء منزله موقعا
لممارسته هوايته في التصوير والاخراج
وجهزه بحفر الخنادق والمؤثرات الاخرى وذلك
بمساعده افراد من عائلته واصدقائه
المقربين يظهر العمل في صورته النهائيه
الجميله الزهراني تخصص في الصور الاكشن
لكنه واجهه عقبات خاصه عبر منصه التيك توك
تجاه هذا النوع من التصوير وجعله يسلك خطا
رومانسيه في بعض اعمال
[موسيقى]
طيب فواز بدايه الحديث
كيف بديت مع الاخراج والتصوير اعمال
الحروب
هو هو حوش فاضي اعطاني الوان الله يعطيه
العافيه هو ما يجي عن اللي صاير الان في
الحوش
بالضبط بالضبط
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله اول شيء يعني انا ما اعتبر انه
وصلت مرحله يعني مرحله الاحتراف
انا تعلم لسه يعني
وطورتها حبه حبه بالتركيز على النقطه
نفسها يعني على ما تفرعت ركزت على نقطه
انه انا
مخرج اكشن ومعارك
وموديل اكشن وممثل اكشن فعلشان كده طولت
نفسي النقطه هذه عشان اكون اقوى طيب
ترسم تحديث
بالضبط
الفترات الاخيره عشان همم لما انزل على
السته
اركز على راسي
من اول يعني
اعطالك الورقه الذكرى اللي كنت انسى
الفتره الاخيره
انها ناجحه وموهبته كذلك يا فواز كيف رايت
تفاعل المنتجين معك هل تم تقديم عروض لك
على هذه الاعمال بعد مشاهده
بس ان شاء الله قريب يعني ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]